how's it going everybody International
Master Danny wrench here again for chest
comms YouTube channel and boy am I
excited to be here I am high on life
right now having just broadcasted
coverage of round four of why Kinzie
Tata Steel Wieck and Z super chess
tournament with Grandmaster Ben five
gold we had a ton of fun and why did we
have so much fun well because the chess
was awesome and among the incredible
games played today was one of the best
chess games I have ever seen in my life
I kid you not and maybe it's the
caffeine talking or the fact that I
haven't slept in over 48 hours but I'm
going to review a game that was just
just blew my socks off and to make the
experience even more memorable Ben and I
were actually joined by the world
champion playing the black pieces in
this game that's fishy andand if you're
keeping score at home he joined us
during our broadcast on skype to talk
about what happened in the game as far
as his preparation as well as over the
board and his thoughts on his opponents
play Aronian being the world number
three and pretty much everything there
in it was it was an unforgettable
experience tons of things go out to him
for being kind enough she joined was
pretty much just because of the kindness
of his own heart no other reason and he
was probably pretty pumped about having
just played one of the best games he's
played in several years I don't think
that anybody would deny at just just an
incredible game anytime you win with the
black pieces in less than 25 moves
against a 2800 Plus opponent you did
something right so as we're learning
Anand is not to be toyed with in the
semi slob right especially the Moran
variations here we see in mainline
slummy semi Slav and after Dee takes e4
b5 Bishop d3 if you want to see what he
played against Kramnik and his World
Championship victory to take the title
from kramnik several years ago you can
look at the line with a six and a
similar idea happened in this game
actually as once black strikes with c5
which is my black tries to do in this
structure in general it's a careless lob
structure black wants to strike and open
up the bishop here as soon as black does
that he gets compensation for other
sacrifice things such as white having a
big center particularly because that
bishop is so strong he used that
principle to maximum affecting his
Kramnik not once but twice winning two
games
with the black pieces in that World
Championship match the main line going
like this with the critical point coming
here
Anand improving over lots of play before
that with the move Bishop b7 sacrificing
the b5 pawn and playing for all kinds of
interesting and dynamic attacking
chances that's not the subject of
today's video lecture as I said you can
review games all kinds of games you can
use our site chess comm and many other
places you can find those games with
kramnik but Bishop to d6 is the new and
modern way that black is playing right
now in the Moran semi Slav and after
castles castles Queen c2 we were seeing
nothing but theory up until this point
where black is over preparing to break
through c5 again it's pretty common in
the structure that that's exactly what
black wants to do he 5 is also a goal of
his generally but specifically in
variations where black is committed to
the bishop on this diagonal he really
wants to punch this move through White
has to be careful White wants to prevent
that idea but also can't necessarily do
it directly as that allows moves like a5
to undermine the Queen side expansion
without going into too much detail about
the pawn structure here and about all
the details that are going on in the
thought processes of players at the
highest level what I will say is that I
actually have a video lecture over on
the main site covering this game because
this experience was so awesome and
because I thought it was such a great
opportunity to talk more about this
pollen structure that I've done an
entire video lecture series on in this
game anon uses the basic positional
principles of needing c5 to an
incredible dynamic effect just just
awesome and home preparation meats just
being brilliant over the board you're
about to be amazed this was really a ton
of fun and literally just how this just
happened live on Tuesday January 15th
actually so you're seeing this video not
more than 48 hours ago here Aronian
played the move Knight to g5 which
attacks the h7 pawn and as a non
admitted to me and then afterwards he
had looked at this variation in this
idea in his preparation for Boris
Gelfand and the World Championship match
they played back in May
obviously that preparation was never
really used or Aronian would not have
played the way he did today after an on
counteracts at this 95 move with the
aggressive c5 things start to get real
messy the h7 pawn is hanging in multiple
ways black says he doesn't care
it's aggressive and open counterplay all
of a sudden you start to see the
potential black might have on the King
side and Aronian makes the first mistake
here and perhaps his last mistake in the
postgame interview and not admitted that
his preparation suggests that Bishop
takes h7 is actually the critical
variation for white he didn't give us
too much more after that because he
might still use that preparation only
saying that he thought that night takes
h7 was lavon's first mistake at this
moment a non shocked the world with a
with a very exciting move but also a
very principled move when you see all
the blacks pressure Knight to g4 X clam
all the sudden in classical fashion you
start to have visions of the Masters of
old times with double bishops sacrifices
and and a ton of pressure black is
neglecting not only the pawnees just
lost but also the exchange on f8 some
quick calculation tells you that it's
not really a sacrifice of the exchanges
there's nothing white would be able to
do to avoid mate here and as the game
goes on you're going to see that you
could actually argue that Aronian is
already worse here with the white pieces
after that one mistake and had no other
way to get back in the game short of a
non blowing it a move like g3 which
defends the diagonal fails to a
brilliant move that is a common mating
net if you want to pause this video to
try to find it you can but it's Queen h4
booyah exclaim a in your face
camel cake you take that's checkmate
Holmes look at that nothing he can do to
stop this Queen coming in to h2 Black's
attack is is getting out of control here
there may even be other ways to finish
the game off as well like Knight takes
h2 first heading into f3 might actually
be the more accurate way as Queen h4
might possibly build up by moving the F
pawn opening up the Queen so Knight
takes h2 would also do the trick
Queen h4 check and Queen h1 is a ton of
fun will say so Iranian plate f4 but
after C takes d4 C takes d4 we see all
the tricks start to come out black to
play and fade play the first of several
brilliant moves Bishop to c5 putting the
bishop on pre when there's already a
rook on pre a shocking move that when it
was played we knew we were in for
something beautiful the the basic threat
is just to take on d4 with yet pretty
simple and and again if you calculate
some obvious moves like Knight takes f8
Bishop takes d4 check and
tweenage for you see the checkmate is
actually unstoppable looking at the
whole board you can't forget to see that
the key lines occur because of blacks
powerful Bishop on b7 again the dynamic
thing that was unleashed by the correct
pawn structure breakthrough I love it
when positional ideas support beautiful
tactics right like Botvinnik said
tactics serve strategy this is this the
game it really is just incredible
Aronian played a bad move here with
Bishop e2 in the postgame interview are
not admitted to us that after D takes e5
Knight takes e5 White's only move here
is actually the move Queen to e2 lines
with Knight takes f8 would fail to Queen
to d4 check followed by taking on d3 and
the mating and opportunities followed by
Knights one of the Knights coming into
f2 are pretty unstoppable one simple
theme might be just just to show
everybody make them random move one of
the threats is to give a check another
discovered double check and finish off
with a brilliant mating pattern that
you've probably seen before notice the
Venus flytrap doesn't get more beautiful
than that all of black's pieces just
bursting onto the scene on the dark
squares but after Queen - II - instead
of Knight takes F 18 to d4 check King to
h1 and Knight takes D 3 Queen takes g4
is White's resourceful defense because
black cannot just check and pick up the
Queen due to a brilliant Knight f6 check
followed by Queen to the h-file
checkmate white would be turning the
table there pretty amazing stuff right
however after Queen takes g4 King takes
h7 we see a position with equal material
though black is is clearly better in
this situation considering the pressure
and threats on the King side and on says
at this point that might have been
White's best opportunity instead of
Knight - xf8 or D takes e5 as we said
the move Bishop e2 was played which we
all expected some sort of line in an
onset the first line he looked at was
aligned with Bishop takes d4 Knight f2
check and he felt at the end of a
variation like this similar to the other
line material is equal with black
possessing an edge here for sure
considering all the pressure but then he
thought and he plays the move the
brilliant move double x glam Knight d2
e5 every piece is on pre here as far as
the the obvious captures but none of
them are capturing the critical line
after a move like Knight takes f8
becomes clear and is very similar to
something we've already
scene with the Venus flytrap occurring
the same would occur if F takes e5 was
played Queen takes d4 Czech followed by
the the climax the brilliant climax and
white is completely lost
after this brilliant double X clam
mighty d5 let's back this thing up and
show it sports centre time replay
instant replay bam bam bam I could do
that all day all day baby Knight takes
f8 was not played instead Aronian played
the move Bishop takes e4 but at this
point White's position is completely
lost however don't go anywhere because
there's one more incredible treat
waiting for you black probably has
several moves to keep the attack going
and already has a ton of compensation
and threats against the white King but
the most obvious forms to continue the
attack like Queen h4 fail to the move
Queen h7 forcing a Queen trade and head
into an end game where you might still
argue Black has a ton of compensation
but why risk it right instead let's go
get that biscuit f5x clam cutting off
the queen's threat of h7 and threatening
Queen h4 black is officially down a
Brooke if you're counting but who's
counting at this point anons already
shown that he's willing to give up
everybody to finish this thing off in
style and black only has one idea in
mind Queen h4 which is maintenance Ichi
six which is what a running in did
delaying the inevitable
but after Queen to f6 h3 Queen takes g6
obviously this is a bluff as Queen aged
six would be checkmate Queen to e2 was
met by Queen h5 threatening Queen takes
h3 mate and any move here is losing rook
f3 gives back material and then some
black can win almost everything back and
probably have other ways to win the move
played was Queen to d3 which fell for an
instant interference tactic that caused
resignation Bishop to e3 the last X
claim of the game cutting off the Queen
defense of the h3 pawn and there is
nothing white can do to stop checkmate
within a couple moves the game will be
finished off so once again to see the
final movement instant replay what you
have just witnessed is one of certainly
the game of the year I know 2013 is
young by definitely the game of the
tournament as far as Wieck and Z is
concerned so far and one of the most
excite
Gamze I have seen a long time I love it
when positional themes lead to really
aggressive and dynamic play and it just
proves to show the good preparation and
knowledge of these ideas can really pay
off and an on put on quite the show for
us just a couple days ago over on chess
comm TV we appreciate him joining us and
we hope that everyone continues to
follow our coverage over there
see you around on the main site hope you
enjoyed this video and I'll see you
around on chess comm